hey guys Ryan right here there's a lot
of people have been asked me to watch
this trailer called earth to echo I'm
excited to watch this trailer because a
lot of you guys are and I see it's a
sci-fi movie I like a good science
fiction I practically live in science
fiction all the girls that come on the
channel
Lauren Kat Alyssa Veronica Marie even
feel like I'm missing something
and Sally I usually imagine we are
creatures and the we are mating Sally is
usually a dragon lauren is sometimes a
spaceship I've always wanted to [ __ ] a
spaceship Alyssa she's actually not a
creature too much I mean she's a regular
creature she's just she's just a panda
and Cat Cat she's uh she's a cat Marie
well Marie already kind of looks like a
creature so yeah and I bang all them at
the same time earth to echo earth to
echo earth to echo echo I hope that's
how it sounds at the end earth to echo
echo echo it's like super 8 but bounce
but it
kids are stupid they should have called
the police or something
whoa no way like pointy balls are scary
kids how how do they know what it says
oh wow it's so cute
oh damn like everywhere
wow that looks [ __ ] sweet I cannot
wait to watch that that's one of the
most exciting two others I've seen but
there's a lot I'm trying to catch up on
a lot of trailers and of Wow
that movie looks amazing I mean does
have that like super AET feel about it
but found footage style yeah but it's
still like it the way it's all captured
I love the science fiction's GGI teases
and stuff like it does look like gonna
be bombarded with CGI but it's into
coming at the right times that just like
Scott the kid actors are good though
like usually in these kinds of movies
the one concerns are the kid actors
gonna be great you know you want them to
be great and so I hope they're great my
point of trying to convey is um I want
them to be great anyway yeah looks like
an awesome sci-fi film I got chills all
over the [ __ ] body right here man
damn my nipples rose like it was
nobody's business man I'm telling you it
was like the Titanic but in Reverse hey
guys thank you for recommending that
trailer to me that looks well worth my
time and my time is precious if you're
new to the channel subscribe please
click it and they said I should talk
more about this and by day I mean the
business men out there who happen to
encounter and decide to give me a bunch
of advice so I was like fine I'll listen
to you they say youtubers should say
[ __ ] like this so I guess I'm a youtuber
now follow me on Twitter at the real
Ryan Wright D a repl Ryan Wright follow
the real Rejects on Twitter we have a
Facebook - and an Instagram [ __ ]
follow us on all that [ __ ] Jerry a zone
called reasons to Jerry salamander Sally
Lauren underscore gah Alyssa be crazy
Kat daus [ __ ] Marie doesn't have one
that's the shoutouts I wanted to give
Tucker
debord he said could I eat a shout-out
I'm a huge fan and what all the stuff I
love reading these comments in these
shout out requests because there's a lot
of misspelled words but I'm not smart I
read it and I try to figure out what you
guys are saying so yeah could I
shoutout I'm assuming you are a gangster
I'm a huge feign um but if I were too
soon what a feign is I imagine like a
vampire's vagina
VV anyway Tucker - bored you want to
shout out so here's your honorable
mention my friends bros necessary videos
he said please guys shout out and I was
like okay calm down child just hear that
fed him some goldfish crackers and I
said I give them a shout-out so here it
is bros necessary videos or you do you
have necessary videos because that's a
very [ __ ] up name if you don't have
necessary videos put some worthwhile
content on there lewiston rants and I'm
not unsubscribe being to you man you're
awesome I'm a true fan smiley face dude
it's cool to know I got a true fan out
there a lot of liar fans they pissed me
off
but you're a true fan so thank you my
friend Louis you stay classy because you
know what men that Hispanic Puerto Rican
dick of yours is gonna get you a long
way